[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime Deli the
lead detective in an Iowa child
kidnapping and murder case takes the
stand detailing some of the most
important evidence found near the
ten-year-old's remains was there
something that you noted about the hair
that was of importance to you there was
seashells in them plus an incredulous
Henry Dinkins the prime suspect is
brought in for questioning
these are my kids we have Gabriel gavel
coverage of this bench trial bringing
you testimony as well as legal analysis
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
foreign
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber it is the start of a new
week in the bench trial of Henry Dinkins
the man accused of kidnapping and
killing a 10 year old girl on Monday we
saw more of dinkin's interactions with
police in the hours and days after
breesia Terrell went missing now briasia
and her half-brother were staying with
Henry Dinkins and his girlfriend Andrea
overnight back in 2020. now Dickens is
her brother's father he's not related by
blood debris Asia but at some point it
is believed that Dinkins took briasia
from the apartment and killed her her
disappearance prompted a massive search
but remains weren't found until nearly a
year later when fishermen spotted her
body in a pond about 25 miles away from
Davenport in March of 2021. at the time
Dinkins was locked up on an unrelated
charge for failing to register as a sex
offender but when briegia's remains were
found police charged him with kidnapping
and murder the prosecution played
Dinkins police interrogation for the
judge on Monday so this is a bench trial
by the way there's no jury
okay you know what I'm saying but the
I guess where is the issue of like you
just want dictate of what we see or no I
don't know no I just like you don't say
I I looked at it like
I had no problem opening my phone for
you yeah I'm saying okay I don't have
nothing I don't have nothing to hide in
my phone from you okay now you know what
I'm saying nothing at all so that's the
reason I will open it for you gotcha I
just don't want nobody all in my phone
I got suspicious with my own kids man
these are my kids
I mean I'm saying it would clear any
suspicion right
listen I I mean I know you know your job
you know what I'm saying I know what you
have to do I know what you have to do
you know yeah and and and I and I don't
have no no issues with that period but
these are my kids bro
um this is crazy man yeah I mean this is
like I mean it's a
I'm all hurt for Aisha because you know
what I'm saying that you know she had
them you know what I mean and my baby
mama you know what I'm saying like I
said I know she feels some type of way
behind it you know what I'm saying but
like I told her you know what I'm saying
you know she like Henry you should have
had more of a watch
you know what I'm saying
I ain't never have to watch my kids like
that
you know what I'm saying never even when
I used to keep her inbury yeah I mean
every ending you know what I'm saying I
never have to because my kids you know
what I'm saying we communicate what do
you think happened big bro you know I
mean I'm not really even trying to even
put up
a thumb on it a finger on it I don't
know yeah you feel me yeah I don't know
what I'm saying I'm not gonna say
something that I don't know I pray to
God that
they find my baby you know what I mean
because
okay time to bring in my co-hosts and
top star legal analyst Terry Austin
Brian buckmeyer Brian I'm going to start
with you we know what the prosecution is
going to say with this video right
they're going to say it's consciousness
of guilt he's talking so much he's
acting suspiciously what can the defense
do with that interrogation I actually
think the defense can really lean into
some of the what I would consider as a
new father the negative tropes of being
a father that you're not really having
an eye on the children you're kind of
doing that whole sitting on the couch
watching TV and every time it gets too
quiet you're like hey what you're doing
over there because he's not really
paying attention to the children and and
the mother of the children has every
right to be angry how dare you be
watching the children and one go missing
but you can kind of play the dumb dad
card and I think a lot of people will
understand and believe that and so this
video where he clearly says these are my
children he's claiming ownership of
children that are not even born to him
but he's like just hey the way that I
watch children is not with that Eagle
Eye I think a lot of parents would
understand that it might not look at
this as consciousness of guilt but just
being a father who doesn't quite have
his eye on the ball well one of the
children is actually his right but I
guess the thing is here Terry
he was the last per the evidence has
suggested he was the last person with
briasia she was under his care his
custody his control and I think you
could say obviously he he did it or did
the prosecution jump to conclusions is
this a rush to say he's to blame so far
what you've seen in the trial what do
you think this is not a rush I think
they jumped to the right conclusion here
Not only was brie Asia in his care in
custody he's sitting there and he's
saying you know this is my baby when in
fact he really hasn't been with her for
most of her life and it makes it seem as
though he's trying to act like he's
feeling bad and people should have
sympathy for him when obviously the
girlfriend saw him outside the window at
3 30 in the morning next to the carb
reagent with standing why why was that
happening so I don't think the
prosecution jumped to conclusions I
think they came to the exact right
conclusion that this person was taking
care of her and all of a sudden now
she's gone assuming all that's true
because the defense has been very to
poke at The credibility of some of these
Witnesses and what they saw but we have
a lot more to talk on this because still
ahead on Long crime daily our coverage
of the Henry Dinkins murder case will
continue the lead detective takes the
stand revealing what he saw at the scene
where Asia Terrell's body was found and
what he learned about a possible murder
weapon
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody we're continuing our coverage
now of the murder of breesia Terrell out
in Davenport Iowa she had been staying
overnight with her half-brother's father
when she was reported missing but her
body was founded upon months later and
the lead detective described why they
believed the body to be Brie Asia's and
significant evidence regarding a gun
it was dark by the time I got there
I was able to go from a distance observe
the skeletal remains and there was a
flip-flop that was near the remains as
well and then also some hair was there
something that you noted about the hair
that was of import to you there was
seashells in them again another
description provided by Aisha when her
remains were recovered were their
projectiles located in the area of her
remains there was okay by virtue of that
was the area searched for any type of
casings yes were there any casings found
no when the gun was recovered from the
pond what type of gun was it again
revolver and so then did that make sense
that there were no casings found that
would match that'd be indicative of what
we found at the scene yes okay
all right I want to break this down I'll
start with you Terry so this revolver is
found near her remains but isn't there
no evidence directly linking it back to
the defendant Henry Dinkins like there's
no shell casings my understanding no
fingerprints at least that hasn't been
identified right so so what do you think
about that yeah I think that's a big
problem for the state you know they have
this gun and clearly you know she's only
skittlesful now there's no real remains
to determine the cause and manner of the
death here obviously it's a homicide but
that gun is not directly linked to
Dinkins they don't have him registered
with a gun at all they don't have the
shell casings to say that it was that
gun and it was those shell casing so
they're missing some important evidence
here to say that Dinkins was the one who
actually shot her with that gun he may
have other guns but they can't say
whether or not this is the gun that was
found next to her and they can't match
any other guns so you know it's a
missing gun case it doesn't mean we
won't get a conviction it just means
they are missing that piece of evidence
let's talk about that because if this
was in front of a jury we could say you
know that you need one hold out for a
hung jury this is a bench trial there's
one Trier of fact here there's one
person that they have to convince and I
keep wondering as we listen to this was
it a wise decision on the part of the
defense to opt for a bench trial meaning
having the judge and not a jury I mean
hindsight is 20 20. if the defense goes
up and wins this case and I say are they
going to say right now I think it would
have been better as a jury trial than a
bench trial the defense gets to turn on
say Brian you were wrong I won the case
but we're waiting to see what the
verdict comes out when I think of a
bench case or a bench trial sorry I
think of a case of like for example and
I know we did this case in the past and
please tell me the one that it is we're
like you can't really determine if the
person killed someone but there's
allegations of like sexually assaulting
a dead body I don't want to be the
defense attorney arguing to a jury it's
not rape if the body is dead like that's
not a conversation when I told people
that's the conversation you want to have
with a judge because that's a very
technical argument here I don't see the
technical argue humans that I think I
would want only for a judge to decide I
see arguments that 12 people might not
be all on the same page with the gun is
it is is he being shady in this
interrogation these are questions that I
want 12 people to battle over and I
might just get one hold out to win I
don't think this is the case that a
defense wants a jury trial amongst bench
trial I think I would have gone for a
journey I agree with you I would think
more of a bench trial would be like a
Michelle Carter case where there was a
discreet legal issue about whether text
messages would constitute manslaughter
she was ultimately convicted there but I
see what your point